- Welcome back y'all!
We're here with the cast
of "God's Favorite Idiot"
on Netflix.
(audience applauding)
Melissa McCarthy, Ben Falcone,
Leslie Bibb and Kevin Dunn.
So this is a group
(audience cheering)
of passionate and creative people.
So we thought it would be a good time
to talk about the things
we love most in life.
Some of which might be a
little weirder than others.
That's right, it's time
to come clean about our
(gentle music)
- [Computer] Obsessions.
(audience applauding and cheering)
- All right, yep it's time once
again to own our obsessions.
I've been so embarrassed
by this game on this show.
I don't get embarrassed,
but I feel like I should be.
My Dorito thing didn't go over well.
- You do like Cheeto fluff
or something you like.
- Oh my God! Okay, here's the thing.
- Is it the dust?
- I don't like Doritos, the chips.
- Oh yeah.
- Sorry. But I love
licking the cheese off.
(Cast and audience laugh and applaud)
And my tongue will feel
like, you know, like a cat.
- Like sandpaper.
Because I just, I really,
it's one of my weird things
and I got shamed for it on the show.
- That's wonderful.
- It's weird, but I don't like the chip.
I don't like how the chip
tastes or like either,
but I love the cheese,
I don't know, it's just.
- I have such a visual of you like.
- I know am I, I
I literally have a separate bag, which
- For disposal?
- You know Doritos dust.
- It's a real thing.
- You can package it for
- No, for my birthday my
assistant made the dust.
I know.
Okay. So here's how this works.
I'm gonna have a slightly
less weird one today.
I'll hit this button and
a topic will be selected
by our super random, super computer.
Then the person obsessed
with the topic will own up
and sell us on whatever it is
they love like Dorito dust.
- Oh, that's impossible to top.
- I like the word Dorito dust.
- Let's, it's really
- I want that on a sweatshirt.
- What are you wearing?
I'm wearing Dorito dust.
(audience laughs)
- Here we go, lets see who goes first.
(gentle music)
- [Computer] Obsessions.
- Well, it kind of sounds like porn music.
- I mean, it does.
(audience laughs)
- It's a horny vibe today.
- It's a sexy obsession, I like it.
- How are you guys
doing with the lockdown?
It seems like you might
need to get out a little.
(guitarist pulls the strings)
- They're like, we must
play something sexy.
Okay, so Leslie, who is obsessed
you're obsessed with talking to dogs?
- I I'm, I'm so obsessed
with dogs, but I realized
I started doing this thing where,
when I walk through New York,
I usually have earbuds in
and I just talk to dogs,
but I don't realize I'm talking out loud
(high pitched squeal)
and I just do a voice
and I'm like hello little snoots,
and I talk and I talk
(audience laughs)
but I'll have like complete conversations.
- I find that totally normal.
- Yeah.
- You find it normal?
- Yeah I talk to dogs all the time.
- Do you talk to people?
- No, no.
There's a guy on my block called Dewey.
(baby voice) I talk to
him, he's little Dewey.
Hi Dewey.
- Oh my gosh.
- I have different, you know.
- What does the owner do?
- I feel like it's odd.
- You think it's odd?
- I feel no, no.
- Listen, Miss Dust.
(audience laughs)
- No I talk to dogs, I feel
like it's odd not to go
"hi human" next to the dog.
- So, well they don't wanna say hi to you.
- Yeah, humans can be a let down sometimes
they can judge you so harshly
for coming, I come in hot.
- Okay, here we go, next one.
(gentle music)
- [Computer] Obsessions.
- Wait, what?
Melissa is obsessed with, is it, Ina, Ena?
- (gasps) Ina
- Ina Garten?
- Oh my God.
- Ina Garten.
- You don't know
- WWIG what would Ina Garten do?
- Wait wait, I don't know this person.
- What?
(audience gasps)
- Oh my God, what?
- Ina I'm sorry. Ina I'm so sorry.
Ina Garten.
Wait, what? How did, does
everyone, everyone knows?
- She started in the government.
- No people said, no, I have friends.
- Who said no?
- People said no.
- Ina Garten and her husband, Jeffrey?
- Is this like a famous
actor from like back in the?
(audience gasps)
- No she started in the government.
Then she became, she bought a little shop.
She didn't know anything
about running a restaurant.
And then she started the Barefoot Contessa
and she does a cooking
show and amazing cookbooks.
But there is a calmness
to her that that was like
like most people have their
kids watch like a cartoon
before bed.
We would always watch
with Vivvy, my oldest.
We would watch Ina Garten
and like Ina was one of
her first words, also ganache.
She would go "Ina, Ina" and then "gana"
- So she cooks?
- She cooks, but it's like,
you know, she makes something.
She's like, how bad can that be?
(audience laughs)
Like everything's just like oh,
or something doesn't look good, she goes
you don't want it to look
like the dog's dinner.
And she's just in a little
bob and a crisp cotton shirt.
- She's just so chill, it's like
- Oh I like that, yeah.
- Yeah.
- She's wonderful.
- She should run for president.
- All right, okay, I feel
judged but I'm gonna watch it
- You are being judged.
- Next one.
(gentle music)
- [Computer] Obsessions.
- Oh, Kevin is obsessed with feeding deer.
That's nice, you're like snow white.
I like that.
Yeah, feeding deer I like that.
- Yeah
- You like feed wild animals
in general or just deer?
- No, I, I, I live in Texas now.
- Oh.
- The guy that we bought
the house from said
yeah I feed the deer once in a while.
So I was like, okay.
And there's a lot of them.
- Yeah.
- Like out of your hand?
- No, they don't eat from your hand.
But they, I mean, there's like
30 to 40 deer in the yard.
Like, like
- My brother-in-law does
this in North Carolina.
They come up right to the
yard and he just like.
- They're waiting
- Wait 30 or 40?
- Yeah. And they
- That's a heard.
- Yeah. I give them, you know, people say,
ah you give 'em corn.
But I found, you know, it's
the good, the pellets are good
because there's, you
know, protein in them.
So I, I mix three to one.
- Oh my God, look at you.
- You are the deers Ina Garten.
- And they just wait, you know?
- They're like, have
you been to Dunns today,
he's got a ratio.
(audience laughs)
- And they're not, you
don't really recognize them.
But there's a couple, I recognize.
- Do you talk to them?
- He talks to animals.
- Oh yeah.
It's it's, what's your
I'm like, hello ladies.
- Hello lady.
- Cause it's your, bunch of doe's
and then a bunch of
little spikes and yeah.
- That's sweet.
- I love that.
Okay, next one. Here we go.
(gentle music)
- [Computer] Obsessions.
- Wait, Melissa and Ben beer at 12:01 PM.
Is this so you don't get judged or?
- It's in the afternoon.
- It's, that's afternoon.
- It's been a couple elevens.
There's been some 11:47's I won't lie
but usually it's like ding and we're like
should we? I don't know.
What are you doing?
We're just sitting. I don't know.
- So let's, you wanna beer?
Well, if you want one and I
- I don't want to have it alone.
- I don't want you drink alone.
Yeah. Oh my God I love that.
That you have to wait for
12:01, that's amazing.
Okay.
- Do you say beer O clock?
- We do.
- We do or beer thirty.
(audience laughs)
- I just feel like I'm missing
out on so much next door
but it's fine.
Once again, I'm just
hanging out on my couch.
I'm just tired.
(audience laughs)
Okay. And those are our
(gentle music)
- [Computer] Obsessions.
- All right, now you know everything.
"God's Favorite Idiot" which
is so funny and so great,
you've gotta check it out,
it's on Netflix right now.
Also you can see Melissa
in "The Great Giveback",
it premiers on Discovery+
Monday, June 13th.